what up it's Ace cashier on the bootleg
cab show
bootleg cat podcast special guest in
here my guy Ace if you guys do not know
who Ace is Big Time manager in the music
industry managers core day managing
turbo who else you manage tell me
Genesis okay Tommy Genesis a couple
other um
Kubota development so how did you get
started in the music industry because
you're from Boston right yeah from New
Bedford Massachusetts man
um it's like 40 minutes south of Boston
um I had a mutual friend her name is
Suzette James
um she was living in Miami at the time I
was going to school in Florida
and we had to meet you a friend of white
Club John ah yeah yeah so why come out
of concert down in Miami
I came down from Daytona Beach
to kick it with Susie on her college
campus Lynn University at the time it's
in Boca Raton Florida we went down to
watch cloud from Miami at the Fillmore
me and him just connected backstage we
like just
you know he's he was just cool as [__]
and he took a genuine interest to me I
was in school at the time I was playing
scholarship basketball so I wasn't even
in the music industry
St Andrews University
no but through cooking University at
this time in Daytona Beach so you were
going to school in Florida yeah yeah
yeah I was playing scholarship
basketball that's great so you ended up
meeting Wyclef just doing stage through
her yeah he just [__] with you and
then from there from then what happens
with Wyclef I went back to school this
is like my
sophomore year right
um we just stayed in touch unfortunately
he was running for president in Haiti oh
I remember that yeah I forgot he did
that yeah bro what year was that
so
um he lost right he dropped out he got
shot
and he was just like I'm good how do I
not remember Wyclef getting shot trying
to assessing him like the president
you know it wasn't really that that
important they tried to kill white clef
well I mean that's important but like
what the [__] yeah they should attempt
on one of the members of the Fugees and
the other guy is in prison
anyway so continue he was running for
president at the time yeah he was one of
the president at the time and um he was
just using me as like
his young eyes and ears for the
landscape where music was at because
even though he was in politics like it's
like he's still he's still a musician
and he was out of his deal with Sony you
know he had that song with um with Akon
and Lil Wayne that was a smash
I'ma tell you like who told me cash
rules everything around me so get that
little dollar bills the sweetest girl
the sweetest girl
Swedish girls yes sweetest girl
I remember this I remember okay
I was like his last like kind of like
radio like records yeah yeah it was the
last one yeah I remember
so like he had that record in like this
is like two years later when I met him
and he was just like this one like it
was cool to be independent remember like
YouTube like took over TV and was the
Forefront in the centerpiece of all cops
I feel like right now you're really it's
really like the when it's cool to be
independent though right now for real
everybody wants to be Indie and get it
out right now the labels on the dsps
they're like squeezing the juice out of
like there was no known distro kid
you're paying for your own ads like how
are you gonna get into the playlist
where you get visibility for the first
24 to 48 hours playlists actually work
after that it's just visibility but
visibility is everything
awareness I think the Russell's done a
good job getting on playlists that's one
guy Russ Toon Core you know tell me what
what's the irony between both of those
things you just mentioned I know a few
guys who are doing very well work
together on distro kid and on
but if you look at if you just look at
again I'm gonna use this word well I
don't want to get well we'll get to all
this but okay Wyclef 2010 2012. this is
what like
being independent was like cool like you
had like you know Funk Volume you have
okay yes
Strange Music was in the double XL like
it was you could be independent at the
chance was like Acid Rap Chance that was
that right Macklemore both him and
chance were independentish yeah even Mac
Miller like was Rostrum with like that's
independent like well this one was
Independence yeah they were at the time
you know but in any case
um
I was just like putting clef on to like
what was happening at that time right
like J Cole was like
you know it's like Friday Night Lights
all right mixtapes you know what I'm
saying like section 80 Kendrick and [__]
so I was just keeping them privy to like
who was popping and what was going on
and um
well by the time like my senior year
came around like I've been playing ball
my whole life and at a high level I just
got like burnt down tired of it stopped
being fun because it became a business
to me so I reached out the collapse I
was like
yo
I want to be in the music industry right
you know would you want to be like my
Aunt R I'm like yeah that's like I was
certainly consultant in the music
consultant and a r kind of fits the
exact description of what that is and
he's like okay don't call me when you
graduate I'm like dude I'm in college
like I can go pray play a pro overseas
I have a degree and it's like you're
like that's my like stamp of reassurance
when I get out of college like call me
when you graduate I'm like I graduated
today I quit yeah bro so I [__] I did
I mean I I graduated I just I went out
to New York to his crib
we chopped it up and kicked it more and
then I just started making back and
forth trips from like Massachusetts to
New York just getting in the studio and
he was working at Daddy's house
um were you at uh I saw the only time I
saw Wyclef live
was randomly at South by Southwest in
like
2014. I didn't go with him I remember
that but I didn't go he was just on
stage with a guitar Schoolboy Q opened
and it was [__] gnarly it was like
why clef with a guitar and like a
basement in Austin just yeah no he's an
incredible performer he plays every
instrument he's a beast man well um but
you're not I mean in short form that was
kind of how like I got him was just like
I got him a clef I I was like
once I was working with him I was just
bringing in all of the people who were
like my peers who I was a fan of right
but they are fans of Wycliffe right so
because I'm their peer and I'm young and
I'm able to bring them in studio with
clap and put them on records and
curate videos and all types of [__] like
they're looking at me like I'm lit
because they're like this is a legend
and like this is the guy who's next to
him Ace and he relied on me to do that
and he gave me fortunately he gave me
his platform in the green light to be
able to just speak on his behalf and
carry anything around him that I thought
was dope useful and what was in because
he was a little disconnected from it
right right so I built a lot of my
relationships from originally utilizing
clubs like this in my positioning around
him
um but then those relationships as time
would pass like I continue to add value
to them and right they became a
relationship my own so how do you end up
linking up with the ybn kids because you
obviously I met nimir through you yeah
corday through you told me about chord
Ace [__] you were like there's this kid
we're out in Maryland here's the
SoundCloud link yeah like before the
freestyle came out so crazy bro you know
what's crazy Jeff that's a fact you're
really like you really were the first
person who like outside of like me of
course like work with him you were the
first person who's on coordinate for
because
no one even knows that the First music I
heard from Courtney was a SoundCloud
thing bro yeah you sent me a link and it
was like it was before any of those
videos came out it was before he was out
here yeah I just wanted to see your
opinion because you were super
supportive of the ybn [__] you you
always supported us so I wanted your
opinion that's so funny though bro you
really were the first one on them
um now I got a call from my my boy he's
OG
um James he's a lawyer and he was like
yo I got this kid
actually it was for my boy Byron who
called me first
who was working with us on management at
the time he was a part of management
he's like yo um
me and James have this kid why be in the
mirror
and he needs you know he needs a manager
like he's about to be on the road and
he's leaving tomorrow his mom was
involved the first two right his mom was
just always around yeah not business
she's just like right that's her only
child she just like couldn't let him
leave home but I was supposed to go on
like a five-day road trip with Denver
just to go [__] off and party with Coco
right he was on tour with [__] dizzy
sorry but we're about to jump on the
tour bus and go party in Denver Salt
Lake City right Vegas and I got that
call and I didn't know who namir was bro
I was pretty much actually about to be
done with the music industry I was about
to just stay on the brands side of [__]
in um in corporate I was just tired of
like
hustling so much bro and then I got that
call
and he's like yo uh it's a it's a it's a
California leg of a tour and he needs
someone to go I'm like yo I'm about to I
got plans though I'm like about to just
gonna [__] off and he said all right
well I'm just telling you like this
kid's doing a million views a day on
YouTube right now first first ever video
and whoever we put out there is probably
gonna end up bonding with him and that's
gonna be like the solidified position
right so I was like give me five minutes
hung up I was talking to Coco I'm like
y'all checked them out yeah I checked
them out and I'm like oh [__] like eight
million views and
nine days right on this video
ain't [__] yeah it was and if you
remember a million views for a video at
the time it was still like kind of like
that was
traditionally like a big record for an
artist if you had a million views on
YouTube for sure it's not like we hit
the SoundCloud wave right after if you
remember when people could do a million
views in a day but Cole Bennett kind of
changed that yeah now the YouTube [__]
was big for sure yeah before that if you
had a million views that was a big
record so for him to have like eight
million views in nine days I was like yo
I can't miss this opportunity so I met
him at the Mondrian like an hour later
it's like one in the morning found out
that we didn't have a bus driver it was
a shitty van I was gonna have to drive
it I had no license
I showed back up four hours later like
five in the morning jumped in
with like five of these like little wild
young kids now Mary was super cool he's
pretty quiet he didn't know what the
[__] was happening bro like this is all
happening so fast and we went on like uh
six City California run who like kind of
like the shittiest towns in California
like Bakersfield
yes surprise Now Fresno was one it was
like what what's was it not Orlando no
that aletta's local it was like um
Oxnard
no that's a pretty cool town to be
Modesto Stockton it was Stockton was one
of them no Modesto was one of them yeah
and then it went way up into Humboldt
County bro like where people don't even
go but we bought and then we came back
down into Arizona so we bonded we got
real close and the rest was kind of
History bro like you know he my man
moved in with me no I know he was living
with you for a while
the hype man whose name is Glizzy
I had our DJ
living with us but I have like five of
these old [__] living in my life Jesus
with [__] two dogs and then Amir went
and bought a dog from Jazz Prince
and it was a it was a
um
Almighty Jay living with you when he was
[__] Blac Chyna
yeah I made the phone call like I called
TMZ
to pull up on him outside of the bowling
alley with China
yo I was on a plane plane was about to
take off he calls me he's like yo we're
at the bowling alley
um because he was [__] with China for
like two weeks but I'm like you know we
gotta get this out bro like this is like
gold bro you [__] China like right
Jay's all skinny he's like 18. so I'm
like yo at some point you just gotta let
me know when y'all out in public and I'm
I'm gonna do what I gotta do he calls me
he's like yo I'm at the bowling out with
China I'm about to leave I was like yo I
need you to hold her there for 10
minutes I'm gonna call TMZ and have him
pull up
he's like ah yo I don't know if I can
hold her but I'm gonna try my planes
won't leave in like five minutes
so I'm like yo where you guys at he's
like man we're going up the left
entrance out the the side that goes into
the parking lot I need you to go out the
other side the other side on the street
side this bush is there TMZ's way he
said I I I'm a redirecting hold on I'm
gonna call you right back
my plane took off so now I'm sitting
there in the air waiting right Wi-Fi
kicks in in like 30 minutes he texted me
he's like yo my bad he's like yo they
got it they got it they all jumped out
she's pissed I'm like that's perfect
they got it though he's like yeah I was
like what did you do he was like I just
act like I didn't know what was going on
I was like what did she do he's like she
just kept on walking
she's pissed though bro I'm like yo it
don't matter we got it yo the next day
so I'm flying cross country right
to New York so I landed in New York
off a red eye
so it's like 6 a.m but it's like 3 A.M
in L.A
y'all like I take a nap in New York
because I'm jet like I wake up like 9
A.M it's already everywhere on the like
all over the [__] media by like six
seven a.m it was [__] everywhere
that's such a weird situation child for
real I wasn't he 18. yeah it was 18. oh
my God he was 18. yo Jay was knocking
him down but I'm not gonna lie down Jay
hit everything bro Jay's hit more
yo Jace hit every bad [__] and in in
Black
in brown American hip-hop culture bro
Jay's hitting tomorrow bro
interesting Jay's hit them all you have
almost any Chick you can think of who's
popping right now
in the female landscape a rat
Almighty Jay's been there Almighty Jay
Almighty Jay's a man what a list he's
the one I can't wait to talk to him and
he's still on a run but now it's just
like it's way more underwrapped because
he's under wraps so at what point in
time did you uh because obviously there
was the ybn split corday dropped the ybn
from his name everyone's still cool you
know everyone's still kosher but like
you kind of just dove in with core day
so what was like the
the like obviously chordates [__] you
know generationally talented guys great
great kids like what was it about core
day that made you want to like really
focus on him
as a client
like once I already
was working with all three of the guys
yeah yeah
he was focused he wanted to be great he
wants to be great he still does but I'm
saying like I noticed that from the very
moment that I started working with chord
A
our conversations were different than
what I was having with Jay and Amir you
know
um and I mean look to like Jay and
amir's defense like namir never like
wanted to be like a professional rapper
right right now we're always made music
even when he was younger but like he
didn't have like that like that bug you
know like burning desire to be he wanted
to be famous he wants to be famous yeah
he wants to be famous yeah yeah actually
yeah and he got famous and then it was
just like he's like what the [__] do I
do now right and everything was
happening so fast namir always just
wanted to be a kid he just wanted to be
famous while doing it right
the industry doesn't really allow you to
do that right right once you have a real
demand like it becomes a business right
so he struggling with that
Jay
always just wanted to [__] [__] so
like and he successful once he achieved
that was he was successful at that it
was hard to keep him
Focus
corday always was like he would wake up
and go to sleep just talking about like
rap music ideas and like what's the next
step and like yo I did this I did that
I'm going to meet with this person I was
networking with this person today this
person hit me up yo what do you think
about this record everything was just
music music so he was focused was it his
idea to do the J Cole reply it was he we
were living together at the time he was
living upstairs in my life he came
downstairs one morning I woke up he came
downstairs
he's like yo I was thinking
mind you I never even heard the J Cole
1985 man yeah I never heard 1985.
um
he came downstairs like yo you know the
1985 record by J Cole I'm like that's on
his new project now I ain't heard it
he's like well basically it's like he's
touching upon like how this new era of
Youth and rappers and kind of like what
you would consider to be the SoundCloud
era you take my generation how
everyone's kind of lost you know a lot
of the mistakes we're making they're not
going to last you know
I feel like making a response for that
on behalf of like my peers and my
generation the youth explaining to him
and even just those who represent that
older generational mentality
like this is why we do this right why
don't you look at it from our
perspective and I'm like sounds dope
killed him but I never heard the
originals right I'm just supporting them
like go do it when he came back and
played me the record I still never heard
the Jake Owen I was just like yo this is
wild yeah without even knowing the yeah
I was gonna say the narration of it is
bridging like this separation in this
Gap that was becoming like really really
obvious that that sounds aware between
traditional of course yeah that was like
SoundCloud [__] and it was like yeah
yeah and I mean there wasn't even
anybody who was doing real rap from the
new school at the time nobody nobody was
making traditional hip-hop for sure yeah
he was like oh wait this kid's 18 and
he's [__] rapping over Eminem and
yeah yeah so I was like that all that
collectively kind of was what made me
really really focus on chord A because I
have a job to do and quite frankly like
people in my position we Empower those
who allow us to do our job and
who see their who take their job
seriously what is like for people who
don't know what a manager does in a like
a role like yourself what is like your
duties as a manager like for people who
are interested in maybe getting into the
music industry or you know
I think I think that
the job description itself
has a few kind of
unwavering core responsibilities for
everybody right no matter what client
you represent because it does vary right
everybody needs of course the things in
one course of course but managing
relationships
managing relationships first and
foremost right you don't even have to
like your manager if you're doing your
job as an artist and your manager is
good at managing relationships you guys
can be extremely successful together
you know what I'm saying because as an
artist it's like
you're the centerpiece like you're
you're the engine of the vehicle like
what you do determines if it goes or not
if your manager is good at managed
relationships people he's likeable he's
Dependable he's charismatic right he's
genuine he's friendly he does good
business by thinking about what the the
other
party is getting out of every equation
not just what you guys are getting so
that people see him as fair you guys can
be great together right that's first
second I think that your manager has to
have
if you're managing a this is a
difference right managing a rapper is
different if you're managing an artist
right
then I think that there has to be a
vision attached to it because
there has to be a long term
goal not just mere sighted
accomplishments right as the focus
when you think of rappers right and this
isn't to discredit anybody but this is
just like if you this is just a fact
there's country artists pop artists
reggae artists
hip-hop artists
right right
when they say rappers it's kind of
because like rap is the evolution of
hip-hop it kind of created its own image
almost like its own genre it's like it
came kind of with the evolution of
production right so like
not necessarily baselines but like 808s
right and scent pads and different
things like that and then the concepts
in the subject matter of what rap talks
about hip-hop stems from like black and
brown people coming from like inner
cities in in just
places in America where your voices you
couldn't be heard right you didn't fit a
certain political stature economic
stature so through break dancing and
graffiti and song form people would
listen now DJing parties DJ yeah people
listen up but then rappers the evolution
that where it's like it represents
black and brown people who have now
achieved those things that we didn't
have now now you have one now you have
money now you have a political stature
right so it's like we can talk about
different subject matters like cars and
wealth and all these different glorified
things we never used to see Raps like
the evolution of hip-hop so I feel like
if you're managing rappers the landscape
of what that lifestyle entails you can
be in the clubs like you can do features
for money
and I love that [__] that's what I love
about how hip-hop has evolved to rap but
in some of the other genres the
traditional genres of like hip-hop
country Pop
um you know reggae r b whatever there
has to be kind of a more long-term goal
that's attached to it
because
those are not cash out genres like rap
has become right and that's why rap is
so saturated it's because there's enough
money in it to satisfy everybody yo what
up it's bootleg cab we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our folks at
my bookie that's right so many ways you
can gamble with my bookie right now man
of course you got NBA playoffs Western
Conference Finals Eastern Conference
Finals they're set I love Celtics vs
Lakers in the finals all right you can
sign up at mybookie.ag right now using
that promo code bootleg and get a very
generous first deposit bonus that's
right and they just got the craziest
like revamp of the online casino it's
like a Las Vegas experience if you play
cards Blackjack roulette uh you shoot
dice whatever it is they have like live
dealers handling it for you wherever
you're at you could be at the airport
and be playing [__] roulette on your
phone it's amazing mybookie.ag sign up
with that promo code bootleg right now
you can bet on Sports you can do slots
you could do Blackjack uh craps whatever
you're into my book AG promo code
bootleg for that first deposit bonus and
it is a generous one also gotta give a
shout out to our family at King Palms
shout out to King Palm man if y'all know
about King Palms you're our new sponsor
on the bootleg kit podcast and they got
such a great product the best thing
about King Palms is it's all organic man
no tobacco in these wraps they're
straight Leafs and the best thing uh
about them is they got this product
their flavor terpene tips all right you
stuff them with your with your product
do we got one here oh we do got one here
all right we have one right here we got
one right here all right you stuff this
with your uh premium cannabis from Hardy
in Las Vegas
all right you smoke up pinch that tip
you're gonna get a burst of flavor yeah
this is the energy drink flavor we got
Peach pineapple we got watermelon wave
also don't forget the goddamn
blue grapes you know what I mean and
also this is a tobacco-free wrap it's
totally organic it's literally a leaf
let me show you what I mean
that is just a big ass Leaf guys all
right so what you could do is go to
kingpom.com weeds flying everywhere
kingpop.com promo code bootleg and uh
you can get 50 off of whatever you order
at kingpom.com and don't forget to check
them out because they're everywhere your
local smoke shop your local liquor store
7-Eleven smoke the King Palm all right
it's organic it ain't like all that
other [__] y'all be [__] stuffing
in your lungs man all right shout out to
kingpom kingpom.com promo code bootleg
right now and it's actually promo code
bootleg Kev
half off everything let's get back to
the interview well yeah I think like
core day I think he had said like in one
of our interviews he turned down like
was it the Gap yeah he turned down like
a crazy bag didn't we tell you that
because I know you were fishing did we
say that oh I ended up saying yeah yeah
it was good yeah but like it's like not
all like I think it'd be corny well I
think most people like most artists or
rappers would be like how much is it yes
yeah yeah
I mean so I think that the
responsibility is coming out to just
like having like a long-term vision for
where you guys want to go right because
now it's kind of going to serve as a
moral compass that allows you to know
what's right and wrong
for you for your business and for the
image of the artist
um again just focusing on like the law
and someone going not near sighted
accomplishments right and then I think
um
I think just like
yeah bro just
no one had knowing how to work
cohesively within a team right so your
representation of the artist so it's not
just managing relationships it's
understanding the functionality of teams
so if it's a label for example you got
to know the difference between your a r
you got no difference between that role
and your product manager your admin
the Executive Vice President of a r
versus the ones who do research right
um your music video commissioner you
know um the legal department
the president versus the CEO you know
versus
you know um because you're kind of like
first versus well you're also kind of
the liaison too between him and the
label right when it comes to certain
communication like yeah you kind of the
liaison between the artists and
everything yeah ultimately and that's
why it's so important for an artist and
a manager to be on the same page
just psychologically and also in terms
of like the orientation of your goals
because you're speaking on their behalf
if you guys are on the same page you're
gonna have a lot of false narrative
conversations on their behalf and
eventually those types of Combos and
narratives get back to the artists and
that's what artists say wait why didn't
I know about this why didn't I yeah you
didn't tell me this my managers having
conversations behind my back yeah you
always hear all kinds of shows yeah so
like when the conversations represent
the artist best those conversations
never get back to the artist because
it's fluid right you know what I'm
saying like transparency is important
yeah and when something's wrong you know
like you know it's like a DJ and also an
entrepreneur and you know many other
things if you have relationships that
are cool artists if you're talking to
their managers you know when it sounds
like it's coming from the manager not
the artist oh for sure it happens a lot
because the manager is not it's not
upholding the representation of the
artist that you know personally right so
when it's clear and it's concise
it feels consistent and it feels or
it'll feel like there'll be times I'll
be talking to like some guy's managers
and other like dude
listen man their Skies clearly putting
the hole out on top of whatever he's
quoting me so he can put it in his
pocket right like it happens and I think
that's the other thing too that would
like to be real with you like
again
rap is different because like it's just
such a lucrative industry where there's
so much money
and it's a cash heavy business so yeah
yo I could tell this promoter 25 and
give my artist 20. yeah for sure but
when you're dealing with almost any
other genre I didn't like that you like
that was just yeah that was just
happening with a big artist who's a
female
um where she found out that like
she was like whoever she was doing
parties with like I think it was her
Road manager was just like taken
yeah lots of bread off the top yeah and
I really do believe that like money is
what
focusing on money putting money first
right is what ruins businesses like you
have to focus on purpose right and long
and like like all that [__] will come it
does if as long as you don't put it
first right because at the end of the
day no one pays you money because you
want money right people pay you for a
service right or a byproduct that you're
selling so if you focus on the quality
of your service where people feel like
they either can't get it anywhere else
or that you just do it better right most
that's what the the new Sun's owner just
made news because he uh
the sons have like a deal with like
Bally Sports for the last like five
years so if you didn't have cable you
can watch Sons games in Phoenix yeah and
he's like [__] that I want my [__] to be
free everywhere yeah so now the sun's
like you could watch like I think
starting next season
like wherever you're at you could either
stream Sons games for free you don't
have to have a leak pass or if you're in
Arizona it's just on the [__] normal
channel three so like and he said I just
heard an interview he was like I don't
give a [__] he's like I give a [__]
about the fans he's like because like
the short-term money doesn't matter like
I'm gonna own this team forever yeah
another thing to remember to build Die
Hard fans I want the more people who
watch the game the more sense fans we
have like what are we doing here like
and the other thing to remember is right
like and I'll I'll draw a comparison in
lineage
with what I'm about to say even with
sports like you brought up the Suns
I'm a Celtics fan right go look at the
Celtics five years ago go get the sun
five years ago right look at any rapper
any hip-hop artist any pop artist just
any act go look at any corporate
business any brand it takes five years
to build a strong yeah an identifiable
business or brand yeah because five
years ago they uh they went to the
Eastern Conference Finals though go look
at what who the Celtics that was the
year that Kyrie was hit and they went to
these in Conference Finals did we um
that was 2018. we went to Eastern
Conference Final yeah and lost to LeBron
James
right but but in any case go look at the
Players no no but nobody expected that
and it was kind of like a it felt like a
it felt like when the Hawks made it to
the Eastern Conference Finals two years
ago nobody was like well and also I
think no the Celtics have built we have
a team that belongs to us now though
Kyrie was a traded player like no no
everybody's drafted everybody's Marcus
Smart Jason Tatum it took time to
develop those players for sure like the
whole Squad is it's been like Robert
Williams these are all people who were
drafted four years of Jason Tatum man if
you think about it
six or seven years ago everybody's like
what the [__] is Danny Haynes doing with
all these picks yeah and it worked out
yeah yeah Devin Booker like so my point
is like it's the same thing my artists
bro like even if you see like a success
that seems to just like come out of
nowhere like why be in the mirror like
like a a yeet or something like that
five years is going to tell you where
it's really at it's either gonna tail
off right because you didn't do the
Necessary Things Brick by Brick to make
sure that you were building something
sustainable or it's going to completely
start
to catapult and incline because you did
all the groundwork to build something
sustainable now you're seeing the food
to your labor pay off so I think that as
a manager like you have to you have to
be focused on that because ain't nobody
bigger than the program right there's no
such thing as elevators they go up just
as fast as they come down yeah you got
to take the stairs because the only way
that you can fall off well literally
infinitively is if you choose to you got
to go back down those steps you have to
make terrible decisions on your behalf
that send you back down them but you
built it yourself
Brick by Brick so at least you have that
option I think that's like obviously
what you guys have been building with
core day it's like it's a fan base it's
a 20-year plan it's not a
you know [__] short-sighted I just
when I think according to be here and I
feel like he'll be here forever so it's
like you know a lot of these guys I
can't say that about yeah and the
hardest part for the artists I'm not
sure anyone's gonna care about Yeet in
three years I could be wrong I could be
wrong I'm this guy's crazy I just don't
think anyone's gonna care personally
platform you get to just say what the
[__] you want I mean shout out to you
nobody can fire you his music's [__]
terrible but it's someone likes it I
like you know what I like you know the
thing that somebody likes Yeet somebody
likes Playboy cardi all this [__] is
just going over my head under my head
what I think is super important too you
know he likes to eat he's [__] peace
yeah yeah
oh this guy this guy's a [__] but you
know what I think it's super important I
think this is so important I think this
is the [__] reason why we have so
many trolls also because it's like
little white kids who don't know
anything about they're gonna grow up
they're gonna be 21 and they're gonna be
like
I'm a little old for this Yeet [__] oh
yeah and then they're gonna be posting
them like that no I didn't but like on
my gram I said the reality is this
conceptual music that's made with intent
and purpose it's always gonna Outlast
yeah the latter and the reason why is
because these young kids who adapt to
[__] so quickly they're young they don't
have responsibilities they're not going
through real things but as they get
older and they have bills they're going
through real relationships they're not
going to still want the same
microwavable [__] yeah they need things
that get them through the times and
relate that relate to them during the
times that they're dealing with them who
are they going to turn to the things
that they once criticized and turned a
cheat to that they didn't understand at
the time right and that's why you have
the scissors and the genetic holes and
the lizzles and the Kendricks and the J
Coles they Outlast everybody for sure
because it's quality yeah I mean I
always say that because people are
always going to go through the same
troubles tribulations life experiences
over and over they just have to reach a
certain age
when it clicks in and some people hit it
earlier than others but it's gonna click
no matter what it's inevitable uh how do
you see AI affecting
what you do and or just the music
industry as a whole
I mean bro you know what's crazy corday
put me onto this website
where
I forget the name of it but like you can
type in celebrities and you can ask
questions about those celebrities and
I take the question is it Chad gbt I
forget he probably that one yeah that's
the main one yeah
I typed a question about an artist and I
said like
what can this artist do I put the
artist's name on it I said what can this
artist do to elevate their career
yo the four responses that came back
we're so [__] on point that I'm like
yo hey I can put managers out of
business and I just can't show up
physically I feel like they can make I
feel like they're gonna end up like
someone's gonna figure out how to make
AI produce records
there's gonna be an app where like hey
you could just be like I want a beat
that sounds like this and uses this riff
and then they're just gonna make a beat
like it's coming but you know the
problem with AI though AI can't AI is
predicated purely on data in the pure
injection and consumption of analytics
it's never going to be able to form an
opinion so and we we're in a lot of work
where nobody has the answers it's it's
just the current it flows and it changes
and tomorrow this can be a trend and the
next day can be a trend and the only way
to keep up with that is if you as a
human being are actually in tune with
something and that's what we're always
going to have over technology is free
thought and opinion free thought and
opinion yeah and you're never going to
be able you can put a price on that of
value because that's why we all have a
job right you know what I'm saying
because to certain degrees
we're all experts in some way shape or
form some more than others some less
than others but like we're doing this
professionally you know what I'm saying
so if not experts we're definitely
professionals AI is not a professional
it's the consumption injection and data
data can be wrong machines are always
wrong at some point and who are you
going to blame like an artist at some
point is going to sit there and look at
like yo you're putting my [__] [__]
your career yeah you're putting my
career in the hands of Technology like
what would you if you're like a let's
say there's an up-and-coming artist
they're [__] in St Louis and they're
like okay I got a local Buzz they don't
have a manager
what would be a fair percentage for that
up and coming artist to give up
to a to a new manager what will be a
fair yeah like because you know we
always hear about people getting taken
advantage of we always hear like you
know their shitty production deals that
happen there's like if you're like like
what would be like a standard fare
percentage for a new artist
to give to a manager who maybe has some
experience to kind of without them
getting kind of like
bent over you know because I hear some
crazy [__] yeah Fair percentage for an
artist to give a brand new manager yeah
no no Brandon like let's say
rapper X has
thirty thousand monthly listings okay
he's running around whatever Hometown
getting 500 to a thousand dollars into a
club has a song kind of doing all right
on Tick Tock no management
someone approaches them what would you
say is like a fair
uh number that that they could get what
they want without getting taken
advantage of
because what is the industry standard
between like 10 20 15 15 okay 15 10 the
minimum 20 on the high okay if you're
doing 10 you should usually have a
partner
because then you're never doing 10 your
co-manager because then like both you
gotta split 10 and it equals the max
which is 20. 20
got to do a lot You Gotta Be You gotta
be bringing a lot and a lot and so
between the 10 and 20 depending on the
certain 15 is safe because like if if
for whatever reason that hopefully is
fair and justifiable the artist decides
that they want to decrease your
percentage there's a good one for you to
come down between from 15 to 10 is the
floor but also this wiggle room for you
as a manager where you can maybe justify
going up yeah if you're just [__]
crushing it right you know what I mean
um
there's also working room where like you
know you may want to bring in a
day-to-day Adventist and give them five
percent so that you can grow as a
manager you can accomplish more things
with your time instead of being spread
in and so the artist has someone around
all the time to be able to handle the
small enough that you're overqualified
to be able to handle even though you can
handle it
we only have so many hours in a day
where do you want to apply your focus
you know you should be doing all the
things that only you are capable of
doing around that artist and bringing
somebody else in who's
qualified to consider themselves a
manager
but not quite for a percentage where the
artist is kicking more out of their
purse are you how involved are you with
the high level high level I mean me and
Cody like we're Partners which is yeah
that's his brand it's his label we just
did a pub deal with posts uh he just I
mean I just saw like a high level Puma
that dropped right yeah yeah yeah we
there they are
I mean I've been wearing them but those
are sick I don't have any but they're
nice
I'll put you on the list for them
they're not no I'm not on any list yeah
we've been with Puma for four years
shout out boom We we've we actually have
the longest current active deal with
Puma yeah of any of their um music
artists that's big
um endorses uh so you know it was it was
something that we've been working on for
two years between the designs the
business of it the roll out the planning
and [__] but yeah it's dope we we did a
high level Puma cut capsule clothing
collab and and went through Nationwide
distribution and Foot Lockers
all throughout the country even in
Puerto Rico which was tight
um yeah that was tight so I mean we're
just focusing on
making like small strategic moves right
in terms of like the collabs we do
because it's really early still right
the Brand's two years old corday's been
in the music industry for four and a
half years right so as the artist gets
bigger everything around them does as
well so we're not in a rush to try to
like explode the brand where you just
want to start building the story right
in terms of like where you see it who we
align with so it's sexy it makes sense
right
um
and you know as we continue to grow
as he continues to grow the brand will
grow with it you know dreamville was an
idea right and then it became a label
was big enough to sign artists and then
they developed a festival and clothing
line and now dreamville was like you
know it's a a very serious multi-million
dollar brand in business
gotta stop the interview real quick to
tell you
take your family at
you baby that's right
side you know it's
about to go get that dick wet you know
what I'm saying it might as well be
really hard it might as well be as hard
as it could possibly be and with
Bluetooth you will achieve such hardness
all right it's seriously amazing uh and
the best part about Bluetooth is you can
find out if it works don't just take my
word for it they're going to give you a
month's supply for free go to
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg get a month supply for free
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg now
it's the same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis minus the awkward
doctor appointment you do not have to go
see some old dude and tell them about
your erectile dysfunction issues in
person because that's a [__] awkward
conversation bruh all you got to do is
go to bluetooth.com right now use the
promo code bootleg they're going to get
you hooked up with a month of supply for
free you just gotta pay five dollars in
shipping no awkward doctor's
appointments same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis plus they got the
Bluetooth mint it's a chewable it's
great tastes like mint it's also the
same active ingredient as Levitra so
summertime's coming fellas you don't
want to underperform make sure your dick
is rocked up baby all right go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code blue
leg
hey man it works what do you want from
me it [__] works everyone should have
a little blue Chew in case of an
emergency
you might have an emergency you need to
pop a blue to it it's a chewable you
know what I mean anyway also got a shout
out to our family at Odd Socks don't
forget go to oddsoxofficial.com promo
code bootleg save 20 off man they got
the underwear that they just dropped uh
last year that's amazing so not only do
you get the most comfortable socks in
the world but you can also get the most
comfortable drawers in the world all the
crazy licenses they gotta have baked
socks they just announced their Hasbro
collection which is crazy because that
means you're going to get Monopoly socks
Transformer socks Power Ranger socks so
much [__] going with Odd Socks plus they
got The Odd Socks Basics my favorite
this is why I wear every day I wear the
basics because they're the most
comfortable socks I've ever put on my
[__] feet so experience the most
comfortable socks in the world with me
oddsocksofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off shout out to Odd Socks let's
get back to the interview
let me ask you this how many times have
you had to be manager bodyguard
bro I had to do that early on when I'm
here that [__] was wild just because
like
because I feel like I I sometimes I'll
see you with and there's been no
security just you yeah so I guess Ace is
just kind of the
the last the last line of defense yeah
it ain't fun though because it's like
like
you know me bodyguarding is like just
like level it like yo come on yo like yo
we're just trying to do this like can
you can y'all move I don't know you just
treat people with respect you know
people always reciprocate it in return
you know bodyguards they're not there
they're like look intimidating being
intimidating and neutralized but when I
first started with namir unfortunately
we couldn't afford to have like a
professional bodyguard on retainer so
like I wasn't really The Bodyguard I was
just like
I guess like the big brother of Parental
figure who was just like moving them
around and such right and so and and
this is like in the very early stages
like in the first like few months you
know what I'm saying it was mad
unsettling though because I'm trying to
do business in like do my job and then I
also have to be like having my head on
swivel looking at like who's looking and
watching because he evoked a lot of
negative energy bro he's talking about
guns and shooting people and killing the
music video yeah and he's mad the first
time I met him I was like bro you're a
good kid
you're a sweetheart I was like I was
like bro you're a good kid like
so like that type of energy had a lot of
other young [__] pulling up and it's
always the young [__] in every city
where everyone's shooting and doing dumb
[__] because they have all that time in
their hands right you know so those were
the that was the [__] I was dealing with
early on was like looking at the looking
out the eyes of like five hoodied up 16
year old is
watching our Sprinter van pull up or
looking at him in the crowd not cheering
not celebrating not joining in on the
crowd interaction they're just there
just to talk [__] and say [__] ybn at
the end of the performance so Jesus yeah
it was a while at time it was fun though
because like at the end of the day it's
like even though [__] does get real I
have no choice but to look at it for
what it is like you guys are [__]
kids for sure you know what I mean uh
what's coming up next man anything you
want to promote or or uh I know you uh
you uh you obviously just signed turbo
which is a big big deal yeah yeah I'm a
partner at range
um which is
wear management company is like I think
12 of us
and then we have a you know a really
really dope staff of like
I think like 60 individuals who all come
from different labels and companies and
things of that nature and um yeah we
just um started working with turbos so
I'm working with him now and um you know
he's dope you know diamond diamond
creditor producer crazy tons of plaques
and he's working on an album oh you know
his debut album which is very very in
premature stages but it's something that
he's gonna be working on
um
we have a really really dope single
coming out I can't say who when I say we
I mean corday
um in June June 16th okay I think it's
gonna shake the world it's it's not just
us it's kind of I can't really say what
it is without giving too much
information but it's something that's
really small big deal coming yeah yeah
it has like several parties involved
that make it something that's like
really Monumental and special for June
16th that's happening
um
quarter as a tour taking place
domestic it'll be announced you know
it'll be in the fall and then go
overseas the world toilets and on the
horizon but yeah bro just just working
and just you know it honestly bro it's
if you talk with anybody but any a r any
manager anybody who's want that fashion
like you it'll be the same thing if I
ask you what you have going on it's all
the things you're doing now okay you
just have to keep it going you have to
keep working at it because everything is
just like one foot in front of the other
you've never really arrived right you
know so there's there's no Finish Line
of course not so just continuously
working bro there it is what are you uh
what do you got coming up Ken what are
you working on no one ever asks you
questions man I want to ask about you no
man I'm just you know trying to rack up
the radio stations on the syndicated
show and uh plug the club baby the club
is there 11 11 Arizona
what made you want to open a club
it was an opportunity that it's not like
I wanted to open a club
it was just an opportunity to fell in my
lap that was
a slam dunk of a gamble is it could be
some homies some good friends that you
have relationships were opening the club
and they saw like nah so one of my close
friends had reached out to me my boy
Corey and he was like hey
There's an opportunity here
uh I'm not going to do it without you
and Davion if you guys are in you know
we we figured it out we kind of
yeah it was just a
it was like a slam dunk yeah so it was
like I mean I'd be because I turned down
opportunities to be a part of clubs in
Phoenix before or in Arizona rather
um this particular opportunity was like
the other parties who were involved
um yeah it was just there was like a
missing
just I mean look there's no hip-hop club
I mean in Scottsdale all the hip-hop
clubs got closer International's done
International clothes that was the [__]
there was a there's a small spot there
called pretty please which is like a
[__] shoebox
but there was really nothing else going
on so it was like damn if we do this the
right way
I think Super Bowl was coming up yeah so
it was like [__] Super Bowl's next year
there's something else happened in
Arizona next year I was just texting you
about it when I found out the Super Bowl
just happened but I think final four is
coming that's what it is the final four
oh dude you're gonna [__] yeah Force
come in we get spring training you know
it's like two weeks of of games dude
yeah yeah spring training is you know a
month and a half there's a lot of [__]
but yeah like about you Kev DJing is
I think DJing in terms of like one of
the core forms
of Art
in music
it's the hardest job
to be it's the hardest job to be
successful at right by way of making a
real living now I'm not talking about
being able to afford bills I'm talking
about like to the point where like you
can continue to progress and you can
make the type of money that we all hope
to make one day and to be able to
acquire things that we want just not
that we need and but you don't have to
worry about bills because DJs all the
time are the last people to get paid
when you look at the overhead costs of a
club or a festival or even if you're
looking at
artists dude like you look at it's like
how much is this DJ's dope but like how
much do they cost okay cool we can go
find another DJ who'll Do it For Less
and that's the problem it's almost like
graphic designers yeah you guys had hit
me up to be corday's first DJ yeah I
would have loved that I wouldn't tell
you I just was like I can't do it man I
got too much I mean look when artists
just start bro we couldn't afford it I
was hoping you would jump in it would
have been tight you know what I mean but
my point is I I love what you're doing
because like you're like the ultra
entrepreneur because you've been able to
take DJing it's just kind of like
the identifiable aspect in the core of
what you do that made everybody give a
[__] right
and then from there you're like okay
if I'm in a DJ
what's the next step of how I can how I
can generate something that's lucrative
like okay let me get the radio then you
get the radio you're like okay cool
radio now is transitioning to podcasts
let me start a podcast
Okay cool so now if I'm on radio and I'm
interviewing artists because I have
relationships with them
what's the next step
let me bring them to a club A Hannibal
Burris is calling let me give you my
phone real quick fire how do you know
that number without his name popping up
oh it is popping up yeah he's yeah we're
about to interview with him
and so I wanted to tell you because I
don't think anybody's ever told you this
one here bro but you deserved yeah it's
dope like you've been able to make a
business out of yourself instead of a
byproduct but a business out of yourself
and up and there's several different
verticals of the bootleg cab Brandon
he's trying to run it up man you know
get it while I can it's hard to do that
bro it's hard to do that that's like
pure entrepreneurialism that's the word
right entrepreneurialism yeah we might
be buying another club too I'm sorry I
might be buying another club too I need
in on that one I'll let you know I need
it on that one bro it's in Cali yeah I
need it I can't tell you what city but
it's in California Modesto [__]
but that's those got to Modesto I'm
actually about this is
I actually start doing nights out there
next Monday I'll be the night show in
Modesto last night yep that's tight
Hannibal burst is here yes Hannibal man
you you was in our video for RP bro rnp
recording Anderson back he made his
quarter he was an acting [__] crazy
all right well listen Ace go follow Ace
with your IG oh people call me it's just
PPL call me Ace boom my guy appreciate
you brother yes sir
hey we gotta wrap up an interview
brought to you by hardean Las Vegas
appreciate y'all watching hey don't
forget when you go to Vegas you got to
go to Hardee man it's the craziest
dispensary you'll ever walk into it
smells like [__] heaven in there all
right get in that Uber when you hit Sin
City tell them take me to hardine
they're gonna take you you're gonna get
a wild selection of the just top top of
the line cannabis the best selection
you'll go uh uh be able to see in the US
Plus on top of that they got the crazy
gear they got the clothes they got the
bikinis they got a wonderful selection
of Bud tenders that are very good at
their job man they'll take care of you
tell them that bootleg have sent you the
bud tenders are Harding don't know what
that means they're gonna get you hooked
up right all right go follow them online
Harding underscore Las Vegas or just go
check out their website too man
hardinglasvegas.com and when you're in
Vegas pull up to Jardin or you're
playing yourself for real